no movie that has a bunch of gargoyles
flying around in it is gonna provoke me
to think one thing where's my gargoyles
movie seriously Goliath Hudson Brooklyn
Broadway Lexington all of them are they
I'd love to see them on the big screen I
flunk enstein so I frankenstein stars
aaron eckhart he plays Frankenstein's
monster and now he's smack metal in
between a war between gargoyles and
demons not werewolves and vampires
because that's been done before this is
gargoyles and demons and that's it yeah
it's not trailer for this movie and I
was like hey guess what looks terrible
more or less this movie's messy from the
start in the messiest sloppiest as way
possible Aaron Eckhart's doing a
voiceover and he's explaining what
happened between him and his creator a
couple of demons jump him out of nowhere
cuz they're like hey we doing a niche
punch boy more or less just gets wrapped
up in this war is i Frankenstein good
that is the question no no it's not it's
guilty-pleasure schlock pleasure is an
operative word in it though and against
those guilty I'm not gonna lie there
were a couple things in this movie I did
enjoy this movie has enjoyment to be
found in it that guilty pleasure kind of
way like I said when aaron eckhart tries
his best he acts his ass off over acts
you bet the point is you can tell he's
like I gotta make this movie good it's
in my hands the chick from the shitty
seasons of Dexter's she's not gonna do
it no it's all me yeah I know she was in
Chuck - yeah I know
Bill Nye plays the leader of the demons
he's a really bad guy he's the same guy
he is in everything like this he's just
a weird old man who talks like this like
he has a speech impediment of some kind
and it's just what he's like is what he
does among the sloppy mess that is the
plot in this movie the premise is simple
enough to where you're like I can find
enjoyment in it because it is good
versus evil and Frankenstein's in the
middle or Frankenstein's monster he's
called Frankenstein a couple times which
doesn't make any sense because he's not
Frankenstein he's Frankenstein's monster
and what I did like is him release the
premise of him the concept of him I like
the fact that there is this big war
going on and he is a wild card he
doesn't have an allegiance he's like I
don't care about your war I care about
me because of all the things in the
world
the thing that has never disappointed me
is me I like characters like that so I
found enjoyment in his character
somewhere in this messy script I mean
Aaron that card in this movie's supposed
to be Frankenstein's monsters you think
you'd look a bit messed up but you look
at him you're like uh you're an
attractive dude with some scars it's
even a scene where he doesn't have a
shirt on and you're like you look like
Ryan Gosling with some stitches he was
too symmetrical I'm just saying it would
have been cool to see different parts of
his body look different maybe one arm is
more muscular than the other arm the
other arms a bit skinnier maybe his
shoulders are lopsided or some [ __ ]
would have been cool to see some variety
from a guy made up of variety smoothie
does have cool action sequences among
action sequences that have a lot of
shitty CGI gargoyles grabbing demons and
tearing them in half in the sky
demons cracking gargoyles over the heads
and killing them doesn't change the fact
this movie is ultimately like van
Helsing actually from what I remember of
Van Helsing I thought once in theaters
the premise is pretty identical it's
gonna go down like this a collection of
teenagers throughout the world are going
to watch this movie like I did when I
watch Street Fighter for the first time
and they're gonna memorize every line in
this movie for some stupid reason the
brain he's just gonna collect it like I
have a street fight is an anomaly I
don't know how I know all the lines in
that movie but I do and it's gonna be
that guilty-pleasure movie where all
their friends look at them they're like
you're so dumb for knowing that movie
but throughout their lives into their
adulthood they can pop the movie on and
be like guilty-pleasure movies that's
this movie that's I Frankenstein I
firmly believe guilty-pleasure movies
have a place among us in the cinematic
world I think this movie had marketing
genius behind it because they were like
let's come out in the latter third of
the month of January so after everyone
has been digesting week after week of
just continual cinematic diarrhea i
Frankenstein comes out and suddenly not
as bad as you thought it was gonna be
it's still bad though but comparatively
not the worst so i frankenstein takes
his place among Street Fighter
Constantine movies like that on the
mental of guilty pleasure movie which
means I Frankenstein would probably be
good if you're drunk
yeah and now there's a party why do
people call him Frankenstein it's
not even his name in the movie Frankish
I was his dad I know drunk Jeremy I get
it it's a guilty pleasure movie what is
your guilty pleasure movie I had the
balls to tell you mine that's mine
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more